AND FLORIDA.
NO STATE INCOME TAX.
ALL RIGHT.
AS YOU CAN SEE WE ARE AWAITING
THE PRESIDENT.
JOINING US FIRST IS THE SOUTH
CAROLINA SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
ALL RIGHT, SENATOR.
OVER THE WEEKEND THEY WERE
GOING TO CAP TO 16,500.
THE NUMBER OF THE PEOPLE
I.C.E. CAN DETAIN.
WE HEAR NOW THERE MATE BE A
BREAKTHROUGH.
I DON'T TRUST IT.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW?
>> I KNOW THE PRESIDENT WILL
NEVER SIGN A BILL THAT CAPS
FED SPACE FOR VIOLENT
OFFENDERS BECAUSE THAT IS
CRAZY.
IT'S DANGEROUS.
YOU WILL INCENTIVIZE MORE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THE PARTY, THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY DOESN'T WANT TO BUILD A
WALL.
AND APPARENTLY, IF YOU COME IN
THE COUNTRY LEGALLY AND WE
CATCH YOU, THEY DON'T WANT TO
HOLD YOU.
SO OTHER THAN THAT, THEY ARE
IN A GOOD SPOT ON BORDER
SECURITY.
>> Sean: OKAY.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
"BREAKTHROUGH" IS?
>> I DON'T.
I KNOW WHAT CANNOT BE IN IT.
YOU CAN'T HAVE A CAP ON BED
SPACE.
THIS IS INTERIOR DETENTION.
WHEN WE CATCH YOU INSIDE THE
COUNTRY.
THERE IS BED SPACES FOR PEOPLE
CAUGHT AT THE BORDER.
BUT IF WE CATCH YOU INSIDE THE
COUNTRY LIKE IN NEW YORK,
MS-13 GANGS, THIS IS WHERE WE
CATCH MOST OF THE CRIMINALS.
THEY GET THROUGH THE BORDER.
THEY GET THEMSELVES INTEGRATED
IN THE COUNTRY.
WE HAVE BEEN DEPORTING
THOUSANDS OF GANG MEMBERS.
THIS WOULD DENY US THE BED
SPACE TO HOLD THEM UNTIL THEY
ARE DEPORTED.
IT'S A DANGEROUS CONCEPT.
THE PRESIDENT WILL NOT AGREE
TO IT.
TO GET MORE WALL MONEY TO
LIMIT BED SPACE IS A BAD,
DANGEROUS DEAL.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE U.S. 284
WHICH I DISCUSSED EARLIER.
THE LANGUAGE IS CLEAR.
I READ THE STATUE.
IT WAS POINTED OUT TO ME BY
SENATOR MIKE LEE OF UTAH, YOUR
COLLEAGUE.
THE LANGUAGE THAT I PUT UP ON
THE SCREEN IS TRISS CALL
CLEAR.
THE -- CRYSTAL CLEAR.
THE PRESIDENT HAS THE RIGHT TO
DO THIS, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
BASICALLY WE HAVE ALLOCATED
MONEY TO DEAL WITH THE DRUGGER
CORRIDORS.
BUT THERE IS ALSO LANGUAGE IN
APPROPRIATION BILL THAT YOU
CAN MOVE AROUND $4 BILLION
INSIDE THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE IN THE DISCRETION OF
THE SECRETARY AND THE
PRESIDENT.
THERE IS WELL OVER $4 BILLION
AVAILABLE TO THE PRESIDENT
UNDER CURRENT LAW.
IN ADDITION TO WHAT THE
CONGRESS WILL GIVE HIM IN THIS
DEAL.
SO I WOULD ASSUME THEY WILL
TAKE THE MONEY AND THE DEAL.
IT WON'T BE ENOUGH.
IT WILL BE WELL SHORT OF $5.7